well I hope everybody's had exhilarating
afternoon at our workshops and sessions
I know some of it was contentious other
parts of it were exciting and other
parts of it were actually educational
and informative and I hope everybody not
just enjoyed themselves but learn
something our final presenter today is
someone who I think is an extraordinary
educator and has been instrumental in
transforming new york city's public
school system her name is Michelle
Cahill and I'm sure many of you know her
she's vice president for national
programs at the Carnegie Corporation and
spent the first four years of the
Bloomberg administration inside the
tweed courthouse which is our Department
of Education moving the New York City
public school system in in a direction
that I think it thought it never could
go into small schools particularly in
high schools focusing on a model that
really reflected the learning needs of
the students in that school and also the
will and the wishes of teachers and
principals it's really just a great
pleasure to welcome Michelle Cahill and
have her here to wrap up for us today
she's a very special person and I know
you'll find this a wonderful session
Thank You Michelle
good afternoon everyone it's quite an
honor to take two people from so many
not only from so many countries but who
are leading the kinds of reforms that
are needed for all of our young people
around the globe as we have such a
rapidly changing societies and asked to
synthesize what went on today so all of
you get to be the critics is this
actually what did go on today and what
so email take some questions afterwards
or comments as well so I tried to
organize today what I heard today what I
had some wonderful others people going
around and listening heard into some
themes so let me start with his major
theme that kicked us off this morning
which is that globalization and
urbanization and understanding education
within the context of a rapidly changing
world so what are those changes that
have come up in our conversations today
well very early on and throughout the
day changes in the economy demands for
higher level levels of literacy and
mathematics but defined through what
that looks like in the real world in the
world of what's needed in in to succeed
in then in the new economies critical
thinking skills problem-solving higher
levels of communication communications
across groups differently from oneself
creativity and learning to learn the
ability to continuously learn new a new
higher skills the ones I was just
talking about are now the currency of
individual social mobility in numerous
countries as well as of economic
competitiveness of the country itself
and the critical lover of human capital
in in all the countries but in in in
some countries more pronounced that is
an hour in our rapidly changing world
human capital may outstripped the
importance of certain kinds of other
natural resources so you the whole
notion of how
important are challenges to this to
economic competitiveness but also to
individual mobility changes in the
mobility of people and challenges to the
fabric of society I think a number of
the speakers this morning talked about
the rural-urban migration how we're
moving to perhaps be seventy-five
percent urban at 2050 is happening all
over the globe and we have massive
migrations of people now we when I was
hearing is that we've had changes in no
one exactly said this but it's the free
flow of capital the notion of the best
vastly changing economies but we also
are having two people voted it's been a
certain way with your feet to move to
where there will be opportunity given
that that's happening and that's
happening inter-country in the sense of
rural urban it's also happening among
countries so are our countries are
having more challenges from diversity of
pop of diversity of population but also
populations who have to be rapidly
brought to higher levels of achievement
this is led to another key focus that
has been throughout the day which is
education for participation in more
complex society that is with the ethical
and moral dimensions and for social
cohesion and stability so a couple of
examples of both of the way I've heard
people raising those those issues from
the US Joel Klein said there's a danger
in the US of an entrepreneurial class
and an underclass mr. yen from China
rural urban disparities growing but
they're also interconnected in the
challenges and the solutions in Finland
high-performing country but concerned
with the next wave greater creativity
integration of social ethos with high
levels of academic competency China
really challenges of excellence and
equity at the same time and moving
rapidly in two dimensions of school
systems
brazil rapid need for accelerating
acceleration for large numbers of
children who have not yet who are just
beginning to even be in the elementary
level of schooling and then secondary
but real changes in raising the issue of
social identity that they're competing
identities sometimes from very well
organized like drug cartels and how do
you engage for social cohesion the other
kinds of identities and we also heard
that from Toronto in the disengagement
of of populations of students who've
been marginalized in that instance
minority boys in particular so I think
we came off with a huge challenge not
that we all didn't know that but that
about that it's like somewhat different
challenge depending upon the country
they'll more so more similarities in the
group that's are here in some countries
we have mature systems that have high
spending and lower mediocre or results
unchanging student outcomes and these
are very often systems that are very
difficult to change because they've been
so matured but in other countries
requiring expansion of access as well as
as as change all throughout everyone
talking about the challenge of
innovation so what were the quick
challenge quickly what were the
challenge is named and then I'm going to
get to what you've all talked about as
the solutions low expectations by
schools and society of children parents
and community with rural migrant or poor
low income status students have
attitudinal problems in the people in
schools off not everyone but the
particularly a man arger wolde speaking
about the attitudinal problems across a
whole system of schools that have been
been going on for many years for very
low income children in which there's not
a belief that this can change or that
they can can do this we certainly had
seen that in the New York City reform in
which we had when we closed in the early
years 23 of our lowest performing high
schools really no proof points know yet
belief that those students could race to
higher levels of standards also belief
about how effective a school can be ten
schools be effective against these big
social problems or or the social
problems have to be solved first and the
notion that we need to make that change
that little or no accountability for
progress schools and families
disconnected from one another parents
viewed as deficits rather than assets to
their children's education and no
accountability our transparency to
parents by the schools but also no
demands made on parents to participate
or be accountable for what's under their
control factory models of school
organizations school system organization
industrial era bureaucracies and also
unions portability design and execute on
key reforms mixed ability among the
countries to draw teachers with the
strongest talent draw from the strongest
talent of young students to teaching and
also deploy those teachers to the
highest needs schools and the and in
some countries low wages and status for
teachers education systems the United
States especially having a hard time
using technology well for innovation
that is we're spending a lot of money on
on something but we haven't mixed our
design and our understanding of what's
needed with the resource at hand in all
the presentations we've heard about the
importance of boldness vision with a
clear purpose innovation and attention
to execution on strategies and learning
from experiments different countries and
cities would leading with different
levers of change but much commonality I
think we've heard across the global
cities the most common prominent
commonality bold actions strong
leadership emphasis on solving problems
never solved before and being
accountable for getting results
specifically we have numbers of comments
today about getting grudge
raishin gains that are also measured by
the validation from the next level of a
schooling or by employed employers
student learning gains and X 18 I could
have equity and excellence at the same
time the key reforms that I heard
everyone speaking about today and I'm
sure this isn't as comprehensive as it
needs to be or may be expressed exactly
the way you're thinking about it but
it's what I heard focus on high
expectations defined as connected to the
new economic demands of a racket lead
changing world and citizenship demands
new definitions of community schooling
new definitions of what the social
contract is or needs to be between
communities stakeholders families
schools in particular you know hearing
about new kinds of demands on new delhi
new strategies for partnering with
parents transparent all the way from
very high level interaction strategies
directly directly with parents to system
strategies of making data a parent or
grading school so parents can see as New
York City is doing what that means it's
trying to get more transparency but a
different relationship with parents
different relationship with businesses
with higher education talked a lot about
different kinds of partnerships and what
I sort of here as a kind of more porous
pneus of school school knowing what it
has to be and be accountable but a
little more open to two other assets and
building social capital a strong focus
on what joel calls the system of good
schools and what various people spoke
about as identifying every school as
having to be functional right and we
talked about that with Brazil and Rio
with 150 schools and treating schools
differently that that sort of notion of
a portfolio of schools some will need
other different strategies though all
with the same internationally
competitive
standards the strong focus on human
capital highly capable principles the
ability to recruit develop and
differentially reward good teachers and
school teams focus on teaching and
learning the relationship between
teacher-student and material but active
roles in creating we heard this from an
Ephraim almost everyone but it was very
strong from Jerusalem Finland we heard
it in the New York City on the critical
I'm sorry I've lost you know the team's
a cream crew teams the critically the
critical inquiry teams the notion that
it's it's a dynamic and that we I think
also added to the conversation was the
dynamic of the tools that can help that
technology based tools importance of the
tools that include new ways of
understanding what how you would tell
whether you're getting to these higher
levels of critical thinking skills and
problem solving and the problem in many
countries that has to be addressed of
low quality assessments so getting to
higher quality assessments that are
actually assessing competencies
assessing mastery assessing performance
capability was it was a theme in a
number of the critical importance of
engaging students cognizant of the
competing identities i said this as the
problem but i think we had some really
interesting solutions there that have
not come up in many other conferences
I've been at which is thinking about
identity as also directly connected with
the academic work that students are
doing this morning the notion of both
stem and steam that to engage the most
disconnected students the students
furthest away from the kind of
achievement that we're looking for was
not to go to remediation was to go to
higher demand more engaging kinds of
curriculum and teaching whether that's
and science and technology or science
technology and arts and also innovating
to see what could bubble up from schools
in that many places talking about
personalized learning and the innovation
that goes along with figuring out new
roles for teachers and students
different modalities of learning and
competency-based and Joel recognized
also Joel Klein the notion that there's
policy in countries that have to be
adjusted for that whether that's what he
was referring to as C time or others
hours Anytime Anywhere learning how one
might think about that just a couple of
more a lot of things about embedding
professional learning in schools that is
building teacher capacity both through
the assessments they get but also
through technology but also through
master teachers other levels in which
actual practice changes at the school
level rather than people are going
somewhere else too so again that's the
porous pneus bringing it bringing things
in having them being used at school
financing differently less bureaucracy
more money under the control of schools
to spur creative solutions use of
incentives and also assessing this are
these working how did the incentives
work how did they not work in what
circumstances which I think of as a
continuous improvement loop that a
number of cities and countries were
talking about and finally to two final
points 1 the critical importance of
scale talking we have a lot of big
cities who are here from hilly really
huge cities that that are here and we
did in here that they're doing this
project here or project there but rather
we're doing this with 150 schools we're
doing this with 250 schools we're doing
this with a thousand teachers where
we're connecting with hundreds of rural
and urban schools across this or we're
doing this for our system of you know
350 schools we're going to do this with
this kind of technology and the notion
which it wasn't very developed but i
think is very much and people might want
to talk about in the next couple of days
which is how do you get to that
do you get to that scale we've been some
conversations during the day at lunch
others you get to that scale by
replication do you get to that scale by
designing for scale at the beginning
those kinds of issues were there and a
final thing and it's really to salute
everyone is here which is managing
controversy and building support to
counter adult action and the critical
importance of leadership that we just
heard demonstrated for us from so many
of the speakers today in what they have
been prepared to risk for themselves and
in their systems to actually drive
toward the kinds of academic learning
and achievement that our students need
in order to for them to have bright
futures and for us to have coherent
cohesive cohesive societies that can
bring us to solve our global problems
thank
questions so we're not going to leave
for approximately 10 minutes so does
anybody have questions or comments no
come on come on anything you disagree
with you want to add there must be
something someone wants to add to this
good I want to ask you a question about
the last point you made because I think
it's very critical and probably critical
to everybody in this room we invited to
this conference people who are working
in government in many large public
education systems and doing
extraordinary work but I emphasize they
are working in government and I'm
wondering if you could comment on your
own experience because Michelle spent
four years working mirna have four and a
half not that she's counting or anything
like that new york city government on
this question of bringing innovation to
scale because we know foundations out
there fun little now you're at a
foundation and we love you and we love
foundations but they tend to fund little
boutique projects out there and then
this question of how do you bring it to
scale how did you do that in New York
City because you did right and we did it
with some help from foundations who took
some some risks not i mean i was in
government then well first of all we had
to have an incredible commitment at the
limera level and the Chancellor level to
do that right and to actually do it
consciously when Joel Klein first spoke
to me we didn't know each other and he
actually just emailed me the day that he
was
nounced for somebody told them to and
asked me what what he should do who we
should think about and I so this is a
great opportunity so I wrote him
everything you should do and he was
interested enough to keep cutting the
conversation but one of the things
that's why I'm telling this story is the
integer that he asked me to drive
innovation so it's a consciousness about
that you really need to break up you
know mature systems and consciously
drive innovation the second thing is
need to have or we needed to have a a
blueprint of what we thought were high
leverage areas of change right and it
could be different and sir michael
barber talks about this a lot it can be
those things may change over time when
you're trying to go from awful to
adequate and from adequate to excellent
or great or outstanding so there may be
some things that need to be done and and
we heard it today I think from Rio that
the notion of putting in a curriculum
right it's not that you don't want
innovation and things to be coming from
everywhere but if there's nothing there
that is connected to standards you might
do something like that first but that's
a scale issue that's a scale that
essentially says we have a first world
in a third chrome system here or
something and we need to bring everybody
to this level because that's a basis in
which they could innovate off of but
also where is there where is there an
area of the system that cannot be
improved that has to be ended and
invented right and that's where I think
you need to design for scale so we
didn't design for use easy example
people call it small schools but it was
essentially to use the design
characteristics of effective schools and
what we know about resiliency of young
people in high risk and
firemans and that they needed to get an
accountability a cohort of teachers and
principal accountable for a cohort of
young people and they would do whatever
needed to happen for those students
right so and to try to make it
manageable in some way but not as an
experiment or a pilot to do 10 schools
said from the beginning we're going to
do from October of 2002 we're going to
do 200 new small schools done more of
those we're going to hold ourselves
accountable but you could not execute on
that without changing the district you
had to change because underneath that I
mean small school sounds like we just
made things small we actually change how
you hired principles gritty came from
that way did personnel committees at
each of the schools to hire at the
school level bringing in talent from one
part of the city that was more
advantaged to other parts of the city we
needed to completely change the way the
system did that so for the first time in
New York City least recent history that
even knew about we're aunt
cross-functional teams and executed on
cross-functional teams meeting three
times a week at seven o'clock in the
morning working backwards from the
September that we were going to open all
of these and holding everyone
accountable in the system for their part
of it so it's and then getting lots of
help from external partners for the new
design did anybody hear something that
they were surprised by today or you know
more curious about either because I
captured it or you heard it in a in a
different way something that was new or
surprising or or made you think about
your own reform or thinking things
somewhat differently yes sir
I you know when and you're from Rio
right oh yeah I'm from Rio when
something that keeps you know that I
think there is a discussion there that
it we talk so much about innovation and
everybody so driven by innovation but I
forgot his name from Finland yes when he
answered or perhaps were you know we get
here because we don't change very much
that's stuck to me because you know it
well but that's we're always looking for
innovation and we're trying so many
different things and you know that if we
didn't if we just stuck to things that
were proven to work and you know looked
for innovation but just we're not so
driven perhaps we could achieve at night
it was just completely different from
what I fat before him and kept on
thinking about it going to do yeah does
anyone else have a comment on that
besides me good from Minnesota's I was
thinking exactly what he she said it was
for me very surprising how humble silent
has been in telling us what they told us
and I think David was talking in the
last panel about globalization or
internalization of education and i think
is great for countries like mine and to
keep always before us behind us and
looking forward but also I think we have
to make a tremendous and exercise in
always looking where we live on however
students are and what are the our
peoples and keep on trying always the
best practices and the best policies but
never forgetting that we are from
earlier and what our students need
that's that's great they what I was
thinking about him and I
I should have brought that brought that
up I think it snowing when something's
working and what's broken what you need
to fix what's a fad or what's a
promising and innovation right so lots
of people ask me why weren't we putting
more resources fairly across all the
high schools in the system and what our
son is in scarce situations it's like
well do you want to make all high school
small schools no these schools are doing
well if these schools they may need an
entirely different approach they may
still need to think about whether
technology could bring their students to
another level but they don't need to
either do the same innovation or they
don't need to we don't need to get
focused on the it right like technology
for everybody or or small for everyone
but the notion of which is very hard in
education of analyzing and segmenting
the problems in the and the and the
solutions while keeping equity as a part
of it I think it's a very good reminder
and the reminder that we do it also is
in a cultural context and that one it's
not that the analytic processes are
probably more transferable than exactly
the same innovation that we can use in
different ways okay thank you thank you
so much Michelle I don't know how you
did that
thank you everybody it's time to get on
the bus don't forget to get on the bus
we're going to a gracie mansion for
dinner and to hear Geoff Canada and
hopefully for a continuation of our
conversation thank you all for a
spectacular day and also we hope to see
everybody in the morning at City Hall
including all of our New York City
delegates we hope you come to hear the
last panel at City Hall and for
breakfast thank you